[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covile 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi anciens ministres ou
directeurs généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de roselyne
bachelot elle n'avait pas encore repris
sa casquette de ministre lorsqu'elle a
été auditionné par les députés
c'est son expérience d'ancienne ministre
de la santé qu'elle est venue partager
au coeur des questions sa gestion de la
grippe h1n1
à l'époque elle avait été très critiqué
pour en avoir trop fait roselyne
bachelot avec une véritable
réhabilitation pendant cette crise
sanitaire on l'écoutent 1m roselyne
bachelot vous avez été ministre en
charge de la santé de mai 2007 novembre
2010 période qui a vu l'émergence
pendant l'année 2009 du virus de la
grippe a h1n1 faisant craindre
l'apparition d'une grave épidémie et
d'une crise sanitaire en france le 24
avril 2009 l'organisation mondiale de la
santé avait en effet lancé une alerte
internationale sur ce virus qui sera
qualifiée de pandémie le 11 juin
cette épidémie et les nombreuses
critiques sur la manière dont la crise a
été gérée par les pouvoirs publics pour
beaucoup apparaissent comme un élément
pouvant expliquer une certaine méfiance
des pouvoirs publics dans les années qui
ont suivi
face aux politiques de prévention
sanitaire je ne doute pas que votre
expérience sera précieuse pour éclairer
donc les travaux de notre mission avant
de vous donner la parole madame la
ministre je vais vous demander de prêter
serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité je
vous invite donc à lever la main droite
et dire je le jure
je remercie madame la ministre je
rappelle donc que cette audition et
publiques diffusées en direct
consultable en vidéo et fera l'objet
d'un compte rendu écrit qui sera publié
madame la ministre je vous sais de la
parole pour un cours propos liminaire
avant notre échange sous forme de
questions réponses
merci
vous avez souhaité entendre dans le
cadre de votre commission d' enquête
relative à la pandémie de kovy 19
pandémie qui continuent d'ailleurs à
sévir
vous l'avez rappelé la présidente j'ai
été moi même
en ma qualité de ministre de la santé
confronté à la pandémie de grippe a h1n1
qualifiée ainsi parle oms cette audition
était donc parfaitement légitime
j'ai bien compris qu'il ne s'agit pas
bien sûr de rouvrir une commission d'
enquête sur la pandémie de 2009
d'autant que les travaux de l'assemblée
nationale ont été particulièrement
exhaustif sous la présidence de monsieur
jean christophe lagarde
mon audition le 15 juin 2010 a duré 3h30
fut complétée par les auditions de
nombreux responsables et la transmission
de tous les documents nécessaires
il convient de rappeler qu'une
commission denquête fut également
diligenté par vos collègues sénateurs
aucun élément dans les dix années qui
ont suivi et qui ont pourtant été riche
en interrogation est remise en cause
aucun élément n'a pu soutenir que
j'avais alors fait des déclarations
fausses ou simplement incomplètes ou
invalider a posteriori bien au contraire
ma conduite et mes décisions ont été
guidés par plusieurs principes conduire
une politique ce n'est pas suivre une
croyance ou encore moins faire un pari
en matière de pandémie infectieuses il
ne peut y avoir qu'une seule conduite
celle de la prévention maximale appuyé
sur des mesures de précaution dans ces
larges toute déchirure dans la grille de
la raquette sera une clé d'entrée d'un
virus toujours sournois et infectieux et
facétieux la décision doit être étayé de
façon scientifique mais je reprendrai
volontiers le mot de john maynard keynes
parlant des économistes pour qualifier
le rôle des scientifiques il convient de
ne pas les mettre au volant mais de les
installer sur la banquette arrière du v
kühl l' expertise doit être également
pluridisciplinaire et faire appel
largement aux sciences humaines et
sociales
le troisième principe est de ne
considérer et de considérer qu'aucune
pandémie ne ressemble à une autre et
qu'il faut se méfier des leçons du passé
et des fameux retour d'expérience dont
nous sommes si friands les plans de
lutte imaginer à froid sont des
brodequins dassier qui contraignent la
décision politique
nous avons besoin d'outils et non de
procédure
dans ce cadre je me garderai bien de
donner des leçons à mes successeurs ni
de juger leurs actions tant je connais
la difficulté de leur tâche
je ne suis pas devant vous pour faire
des commentaires ou exprimer des
opinions mais bien pour expliquer la
genèse et la mise en oeuvre de mes
décisions
je ferai en conclusion de ce propos
liminaire une remarque est un souhait
dans cette pandémie
j'ai reçu le soutien sans faille du
président nicolas sarkozy et du premier
ministre françois fillon
ils ont appuyé et souvent guidé mes
choix sans jamais les empêcher ou même
les ralentir par des considérations
budgétaires
la tenue de cette commission denquête et
pourront à l'occasion de leur exprimer
publiquement ma reconnaissance et mon
respect soyez en remerciés
mon souhait est que nous construisions
ensemble une société résiliente face aux
risques sanitaires et technologiques ou
environnementaux cette lutte ne saurait
relever simplement de décisions des
acteurs publics mais d'une véritable
culture du risque diffusé dans
l'ensemble de la société
il n'y a pas d'un côté des politiques
vilipendé mis en accusation et de
l'autre des citoyens paré de toutes les
vertus et quasiment sanctifié j'ai pu
mesurer les sacrifices l'ingéniosité le
sens du bien commun de tant de français
qu'ils soient soignants qu'un personnel
des administrations ministres et membres
de leurs cabinets tous ceux et celles
qui assurent notre vie au quotidien
pendant ces crises
kylie elle trouve l'expression de ma
reconnaissance merci madame à ministre
avant de passer la parole le rapporteur
et compte tenu de ce que vous venez de
dire sur le fait que vous ne vouliez pas
porter un regard sur la façon dont la
crise sanitaire a été menée cette fois
ci je viens justement vous posez la
deuxième question j'avais préparé dans
un entretien accordé au journal le monde
le 4 mai vous indiquez s'agissant de la
préparation à la grippe a h1n1 et les
commandes coûteuse en masquer vec5 qu'il
n'y avait eu de la part du gouvernement
aucune hésitation qu'à aucun moment
l'aspect budgétaire n'a joué les
considérations budgétaires votre avis
ont-elles pu jouer un rôle trop
important dans les années qui ont suivi
la crise de la grippe et expliquer les
difficultés auxquelles finalement la
france s'est trouvée confrontée début
2020 pour répondre à l'épidémie
je serais bien incapable d'apporter des
jugements d' analyses ayant quitté la
politique en 2012
ayant refusé et de façon itérative de
mon mail et vous reconnaîtrez que je
n'ai jamais failli à cette ligne à cette
ligne éthique que je me suis fixé j'ai
fait des commentaires dans un cadre
journalistique qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ce qu'est le commentaire politique
d' analyse donc est-ce que des
considérations budgétaires ont été à
l'oeuvre
c'est au ministre qui m'ont succédé de
le dire merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci à madame la présidente merci
madame la ministre vous avez eu à gérer
cette crise
qui à l'époque était extrêmement
difficile vous avez eu à en gérer après
ce qui est plus paradoxal aussi des
conséquences et vous avez rappelé les
épisodes sans doute un peu difficile de
ces commission denquête à l'époque ce
qui était en cause c'est de vous
reprocher d'en avoir trop fait avoué au
premier ministre et au président nicolas
sarkozy
je rappelle d'ailleurs que votre
directeur de cabinet ainsi que son
adjoint la santé ont même été auditionné
par la police judiciaire à la suite d'un
référé de la cour des comptes qui
naturellement a débouché sur rien mais
ça situe quand même le contexte auquel
vous avez été confronté donc ce que ce
contexte n'a pas conduit
peut-être est-ce qu'on en fasse passer
par la suite et à une forme de
désarmement alors vous avez déjà répondu
à cette question donc c'est peut-être
une appréciation plus qu'une question
mais est ce que ce n'est pas une
explication aussi à ce qu'on a pu
constater d'ores et déjà dans nos
travaux à la diminution notamment
extrêmement importante du stock de
masques par rapport à la période où vous
étiez ministre et et à celles qu'on a
connues au début de la crise puisqu'on
est passé d'un milliard 700 millions de
masques parce que vous quittez avenue de
ségur
j'ai été trop modeste à 100 millions en
janvier
là-dessus j'aimerais avoir votre
appréciation mais vous avez déjà indiqué
à pas et je souhaiterais savoir une
façon opérationnelle comment les
décisions à l'époque la gestion
opérationnelle de cette crise
s'effectuer à la fois en amont de façon
interministériel la relation avec le
ministre de l'intérieur avec le premier
ministre avec le président de la
république quelle était la chaîne de
commandement
parce qu'on voit aussi dans la crise
actuelle et c'est des questions qui ont
été posées une multiplication des lieux
de décision des cellules de crise
comment la crise a été gérée par rapport
à aux autorités hiérarchiques premier
ministre président de la république et
dans le sens dans la direction inverse
par rapport à vos outils ce dont vous
disposiez et notamment l'eprus comment
vous avez articulé vos décisions ou les
avait mises en oeuvre comment vous les
avez diffusé à la fois au travers de
votre cabinet de la dgs et de l'eprus
qui était aussi le l'autorité
opérationnel l'institution opérationnel
pour reconstituer les stocks
stratégiques et pour mettre en place les
choix politiques que vous aviez décidé
en matière de santé publique il n'y a
pas de demi choix sinon on est dans
l'attitude de la ligne maginot où on
pense que l'ennemi n'attaquera qu'à
certains endroits il n'y a qu'une seule
stratégie qui vaille je le répète c'est
la stratégie de la prévention maximum
car on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
nous savions que le virus a h1n1 était
un myxovirus moins virulent mais plus
contagieuse que la grippe a h5n1 dit
grippe aviaire ou asiatiques
celle ci est en porcine est d'origine
mexicaine
pour autant on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'une reprise de la contagiosité de la
virulence et d'une mutation des virus
nous l'avons déjà observé nous l'avions
observé dans ce qu'on appelle la
mutation norvégienne au moment de la
grippe a h1n1
je trouve assez paradoxal que je sois
crédité moi qui ai voulu que le
l'armement du pays soit complet que je
sois crédité ou débité si l'on veut
d'une baisse de vigilance de l'ensemble
de la société d'en être masqué comme m
pardonnez moi assez comique mais je fais
lui doit ses larges pour prendre les
fautes y compris qu'ils ne sont pas les
miennes
ceci étant les procès dont j'ai été
l'objet les moqueries les mises en cause
ont été d'une telle violence et d'une
telle injustice que je peux la limite
comprendre les craintes que cela a
suscité chez certains les craintes
suscitées chez certains de mes demi
successeur on s'est dit peut-être qu'à
un certain moment il n'y avait plus il y
avait plus de risque à en faire trop
quand faire passer c'est considérer que
l'opinion publique doit gérer la
politique sanitaire du pays
ce qui n'a jamais été ma vision je me
moque de l'opinion publique en ce
domaine
je fais ce qu'il y à faire je n'ai
jamais agi par sondages ni par a priori
et j'espère que mes successeurs en
feront de même
la chaîne du commandement était assez
simple le ministère opérationnel
jusqu'au stade iv de la pandémie il y as
je le rappelle sept niveaux d'échelle d'
alerte pour l' oms jusqu'au stade iv
dans le cadre de ce qui avait été dans
la préparation pandémie liée à la grippe
aviaire le ministère opérationnel était
le ministère de la santé à partir du
passage au stade iv le passage se
faisait au ministère de l'intérieur
car il était estimé que les risques de
troubles à l'ordre public l'emportait
sur les risques sanitaires
c'est peut-être une des premières
difficultés
monsieur le rapporteur que j'ai souligné
quand je parlais des plans qui enferme
la décision politique dans des
brodequins d'acier car la grippe a h1n1
ne méritait sans doute pas au stade iv
le passage se fasse du ministère de la
santé au ministère de l'intérieur
ceci étant je n'ai pas le sentiment que
cela a brouillé la chaîne de
commandement de façon dirimante il faut
rappeler que d'ailleurs dans ce cadre
nous sommes passés très vite au stade ci
sur les indications de leur baisse et
même au stade 6 b sans jamais arriver au
stade 7 qui le blocage évidemment de la
planète et nous mêmes sommes restés en
deçà des préconisations de l'om s
en refusant de passer au stade
préconisée par l' oms
les réunions se sont toujours déroulées
les réunions interministérielles dans le
salon vert de l'elysée sous la
présidence du président de la république
en présence du premier ministre et de
tous les ministres concernés par une
pandémie ministre de l'éducation
ministre des transports ministre de
l'intérieur ministre des affaires
sociales
toutes les décisions ont été validés par
le président de la république sur mes
propositions
il n'y a jamais eu de rupture dans la
chaîne de commandement
elle a été parfaitement clair elle n'a
donné lieu à aucun conflit
j'ai d'ailleurs au moment dé commission
denquête fait parvenir à calendrier de
toutes les réunions telles qu'elles
avaient été tenues
et vous les retrouverez sans problème
dans les archives merci monsieur avoir
plus de questions
alors on va passer aux questions des
groupes jean pierre door pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'ai été le rapporteur de cette
commission d enquête présidée par
monsieur lagarde
elle avait été demandée à l'époque par
le groupe politique qu'elle appartenait
jean christophe lagarde
mais j'ai également été le rapporteur du
plan pandémie à côté de monsieur houssin
et je les dis le plan pandémie 2011 je
le dis depuis le début de cette
commission denquête était un plan
parfaitement équilibré et parfaitement
efficace avec non seulement vous l'avez
rappelé
un nombre considérable de masquer un
nombre considérable de médicaments en
particulier le tamiflu de l'époque mais
également les antibiotiques ainsi que
les vaccins avec la construction de
l'eprus qui a été peu dire la fierté de
ce plan pandémie alors ayant dit tout
cela il faut quand même vous poser
quelques questions qui nous qui nous
trouble ou qui me trouble moitié
premièrement c'est l'impression d'un
tournant dans la gym dans la gestion de
ses stocks puisque entre 2011 et 2020 on
voit qu'on est passé quand même de plus
de 2 milliards de masques à 117 millions
lorsque j'ai posé la question au
ministre le 3 mars dernier à l'assemblée
nationale
donc il ya eu un un véritable tournant
ça pose la question de savoir comment on
aurait pu éviter ça deuxième question
c'est la faiblesse de l'eprus petit à
petit et on en a reparlé tout à l'heure
avec un ministre qui vous a succédé il y
a eu un affaiblissement certain de
l'eprus quand il a été fusionnée dans le
groupe santé publique france même si
c'est pas santé publique france qu'elle
reste l'entière responsabilité
c'est qu'on a réduit la force de l'eprus
à l'intérieur de cette nouvelle agence
dont il ya probablement de ce côté là
quelque chose qu'il faudra revoir car
s'ils ont des armes en fait un pays en
cas de l'agent sanitaire ça devient
grave et on a désarmé effectivement
l'eprus et puis enfin je voudrais vous
demander est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qui a des jupes qui est des
quelques défaillances dans cette gestion
de crise par rapport aux deux crises
successives que vous avez traversé et
que nous avons traversé la crise de la
grippe aviaire en 2003 2004 2005 puis la
crise de h1n1 en 2009 2010 je retrouve
là encore les les rapports vous l'avez
fait à l'époque donc aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous aurez
pu faire je pense que vous pouvez nous
donner quand même quelques réponses mais
écoutez monsieur cher jean pierre door
je suis une tenant de la politique des
masques c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que lors dans une pandémie de type
respiratoire
il faut absolument avoir une politique
de masques préparé très à l'avance ce
n'est pas au moment où la pandémie se
déclare qu'on peut se procurer des
masques
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
constituer ce stock de 1 milliard de
stacks 2e de masques chirurgicaux 728
millions de masques ffp2 que j'ai
complété avec 500 millions de masques
que j'ai complété d'ailleurs à la fin de
la pandémie de grippe pour assurer à mes
successeurs à stoke valable et est
vérifiée
j'ai également en possession du stock de
max qui m avait été léguée si je puis
dire par mes prédécesseurs que je suis
heureuse de saluer car ils m'ont procuré
des outils tout à fait utile dans cette
pandémie
je veux parler de philippe douste blazy
de xavier bertrand que je salue
amicalement de cette salle j'ai fait
donc faits vérifiés par le laboratoire
national de métrologie et d'essais la
validité du stock de masques pour voir
si ces masques parce qu'il suffit pas
d'avoir des masques faut qu'ils soient
en bon état donc le laboratoire d
national d'essais apr a procédé à des
échantillonnages qui ont permis de
vérifier la bonne qualité du stock de
masques
ça a été la première le premier élément
je reviendrai peut-être plus
complètement au détour d'une autre
question sur la politique vaccinale
parce que je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important
et dans quelques semaines quelques mois
le plus tôt je l'espère le gouvernement
sera confronté aux problématiques de la
vaccination il est peut être intéressant
de voir cela donc une politique de
masquer une politique qui est évidemment
pas uniquement au niveau des moyens
matériels à ce niveau des masques
j'ai également équiper les hôpitaux en
ce qu'on appelle des expos c'est à dire
des circulations n'est pas appareils
d'oxygénation extracorporelle pour que
les au moment où les malades arriverait
en détresse respiratoire
les hôpitaux soient encore équipés soit
bien équipé dans ces expos d'ailleurs il
ya certes un réanimateur qui m'ont dit
que dans les hôpitaux on les appelle des
bachelot ça m'a en quelque sorte
sama ça m'a amusé tout de suite avec
l'institut pasteur nous avons livré une
politique de test également important
chalus l'institut pasteur qui a été
d'une réactivité pour dès le 5 mai après
que l'identification du gène au moma et
nous a été transmise par les cdc
américains des courtes séquences du
génome nous permettent de mettre au
point des tests pcr qui permettait de
détecter la grippe en 12 heures la
grippe a h1n1
donc nous avons mené ces trois
opérations d'équipement
bien entendu nous avons mené d'autres
opérations qui relevait plus de la
logistique sanitaires d'abord venant des
pays cibles de la pandémie
la prise de température dans les
aéroports et l'isolément et le
confinement
des malades ainsi détecter et puis ce
qui a été fait dès le début de la de la
pandémie une politique de gestes
barrières qui a été particulièrement
efficace puisqu'elle nous a pratiquement
supprimé les les épidémies d'infection
saisonnière hivernale
là il ya eu un véritable succès dont on
peut regretter qu'il ne se soit pas
prolongée prolongée par la suite
donc c'est ce qui a c'est ce qui a été
fait j'ai j'ai voulu que l'ensemble des
possibilités des pannes et des
stratégies d achat soit soit ainsi fait
je ne pense pas à vous rares oublier
quoi que ce soit dans 7 dans cette
stratégie
mais vous avez posé une deuxième d'un
deuxième volet de votre question en
disant est ce qu'il ya eu des failles
dans cette dans cette stratégie dont on
pourrait se se prétend se prévaloir pour
avancer de façon plus constructive
vous avez parlé de l'eprus j'ai trouvé
un outil remarquable dans l'épreuve ce
n'est pas moi qu'il l'ait créer c'est
monsieur xavier bertrand en 2007 il l'a
fait juste avant que je prenne les
commandes du ministère de la santé
et c'est un outil tout à fait
remarquable et je pense qu'il doit
garder son autonomie parce que la
temporalité d'un établissement de
préparation et deux réserves à l'urgence
sanitaire ne peut pas se mêler avec des
temporalités d'urgence il faut garder
son autonomie à l'eprus on est sur le
temps long et quand on mélange les
contingences quotidiennes avec
l'anticipation long terme les
contingences quotidiennes emporte tout
vous
hélas merci
boris vélo pour les socialistes merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
quelques quelques questions pour les
leçons qu'on peut en tirer pour l'avenir
monsieur houssin été outre directement
la santé délégué interministériel à
shine donc j'aurais aimé savoir ce qui
avait présidé au choix de faire mais
directeur général de la santé un délégué
interministériel et quels avantages l'a
présenté juste avant la préparation à la
gestion de la crise fait la première
question
deuxième question apparaissaient les ars
tout cas elle était dans une phase de
constitution
de quelle manière elles ont été pensées
relativement au risque pandémique est
est ce que l on est c'est une question
que s'est posée la dernière semaine est
ce qu'elles ont une culture de la
gestion de crise dont on pensait qu'elle
pouvait être plutôt du côté des
préfectures et dernière dernière
question dans le rapport de la
commission denquête de juillet 2010 ils
étaient il ya une conclusion qui disait
faute de lignes de séparation claire
entre les experts l'om et ses
laboratoires l'influencent de ces
derniers sur les recommandations de l'om
est-ce apparaît par exemple dans le rôle
donné à la vaccination comme réponse à
une pandémie grippale et dix ans plus
tard dans les auditions auxquelles nous
avons procédé professeur raoul tu as à
nouveau posée la question des conflits
d'intérêts et de ce qu'ils pouvaient
déterminer des choix en terme de a-2 de
traitement je voudrais savoir comment
vous réagissez à ses propos et si vous
avez le sentiment ou pas que les
pratiques ont évolué pendant trois
questions en une
il a été créé suite à la bande
l'épidémie de grippe aviaire h5n1 à une
délégation interministérielle à la
grippe aviaire
c est d'ailleurs assez intéressant de
voir que ce n'était pas une délégation
interministérielle à la grippe ou à la
pandémie même bien une délégation
interministérielle à la grippe aviaire
je rejoins ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans mon propos liminaires sur
les brodequins d'acier des plans c'est
peut-être une des difficultés que j'ai
eu à surmonter dans ce passage entre le
ministère de la santé le ministère de
l'intérieur que cette ce plan tout à
fait bien armés
2 et cette délégation qu'on appelait la
dilga à la grippe aviaire
il ya des outils qui m'ont été utiles
comme le centre de commandement le
chorus les dispositions logistiques
d'une sorte de war room pour gérer pour
ja pour gérer une crise pandémique mais
néanmois je crois qu'il faut aller vers
des structures plus souple posez les
outils mais éviter comme je les dis les
procédures alors les ars ne sont pas
intervenues directement dans cette crise
puisqu'elles ont été préfigurée en avril
2009 et mise sur pied en avril mai 2010
j'ai voulu les ars comme une structure
de régionalisation de l'administration
de la santé regroupant en son sein pas
moins de dix administrations de l'état
et de la sécurité sociale car est à
nouveau la crise que nous venons de
vivre le montre l'administration tuyaux
d'orgue du système sanitaire social et
médico-social est un véritable problème
dans notre pays
j'ai voulu que les personnes qui étaient
nommés à la tête des ars le soit selon
une procédure profondément original
puisque j'ai moi même fait appel
un cabinet de recrutement qui m'a
proposé des listes de candidats ainsi
trier j'ai reçu tous les candidats au
moins pendant une heure et j'ai proposé
au premier ministre et au président de
la république mais 26 directeurs des ars
dont j'ai voulu qu'il soit d'origine
pluridisciplinaire tous mes choix ont
été validés à part 2 qui était
d'ailleurs mon deuxième choix
je ne peux que regretter que par la
suite le poids d'administration et
peut-être était-elle que chaque fois
qu'un ministre veut fourguer un
directeur de cabinet dont il assez ici
que c'est la bonne occasion de le mettre
à un poste comme celui là qui est une
nomination dit en conseil des ministres
mais c'est tout c'est une plaisanterie
j'ouvre les guillemets gelé ferme je
pense que les ars pour moi était une
administration de combat souple
destinées à casser l'organisation tuyaux
d'orgue et surtout pour moi
elle préface est une organisation
régionaliser du système de santé qui
devaient à terme déboucher sur des orcs
dam des objectifs régionaux de dépenses
d'assurance maladie
voilà quelle était ma vision des ars
évidemment il y a une caractéristique
dans la gouvernance française c'est que
ce ne sont pas les ministres qui sont
les parents des ans des réformes qui les
met en oeuvre puisque j'ai quitté le
ministère de la santé
quatre mois après l'installation des
agences régionales de santé
il fallait à cette affaire un pilotage
politique fort et engagé
et quand il n'ya pas de pilotage
politique fort c'est un pilotage
technocratique qui prend la main je dis
quelque chose de général bien sûr si on
y ajoute que l'administration de la
santé contrairement à un lieu commun et
de façon contre intuitive à être une
administration sous administrée quand on
n'a pas assez d'hommes ont fait des
circulaires je demeure néanmoins
persuadé que les ars sont un outil
indispensable et je ne peux que
regretter que la désastreuse réforme
territoriale de 2015 de réduction du
nombre des régions et porter un coup
fatal aux ars obligeant cette
administration adolescente à se
reconfigurer
vous me parlez
ça c'est en je peux rien conviendrait
peut-être de parler des vaccins est de
savoir comment j'ai pratiqué dans ce
domaine pour répondre complètement votre
question parce que si on ne comprend pas
la stratégie vaccinale
on peut imaginer qu'on a acheté ces
vaccins parce que je ne sais pas je
j'étais payée par baxter par gsk par
sanofi ou par novartis
donc il faudrait peut-être que
j'explique ce qui a été fait
si vous le voulez bien merci philippe
igier pour liberté territoire merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure en
démarrant votre propos on doit au
maximum protéger lorsqu'on est en charge
de la santé
face à une telle pandémie ya pas 36
solutions sur des traitements on sait
très bien que comme c'est un nouveau
virus
on ne l'a pas soit on a des vaccins il
est en préparation et live en un jour et
si on protège les populations et on voit
bien qu'il ya eu un déficit de
protection des populations moi la
question que j'aimerais vous poser c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il faut tirer comme
conséquence parce qu'il y aura d'autres
pandémies et donc on doit sortir plus
forts d'une telle crise qui a laissé en
ses 30000 morts malheureusement du côté
30 une personne qui ne sont plus là et
donc votre expertise et votre expérience
ils fonctionnement ministériel là dessus
est pour nous une recommandation
importante
la seconde chose des vaccins arriveront
dans quelques mois est ce que votre
préconisations c'est que toute la
population se vacciner parce qu'on sait
que ce virus a touché que cinq ou six
millions de personnes et que donc
l'exposition à venir peut être très
importante et la troisième chose sur des
agences vous n'est très bien de le
démontrer avec les rh devenu ars et ce
n'est pas le sentiment que ce cas nous
l'avons pour un certain nombre d'entre
nous qui sont là que à la fois santé
publique france à la fois les ars comme
on a créé des agences il n'était plus
coupe
dans directement même s'il y avait une
autorité fonctionnelle du ministre qui
avait pas cette fluidité qu'on peut voir
et que par exemple regrouper les ars ou
du moins les remettre sous la
responsabilité des préfets améliorer la
chaîne de commandement puisqu'on voit
que la réponse sur le terrain était très
différente selon qu'on soit dans un
territoire ou dans un autre merci
beaucoup
du conflit qui a surgi dès la création
des ars entre les préfets et les
directeurs généraux des ars ainsi
qu'avec l'assurance maladie c'est à dire
que dans cette volonté de créer une
structure régionale régionaliser
sanitaires les préfets en mener une
guerre sans merci contre les ars
l'assurance maladie aussi elle ne
voulait pas drs néanmois remettre les
ars
sous la houlette des préfets ne me
paraît pas une bonne stratégie
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de
comment dirais-je de partenariat de
dialogue possible mais je crois qu'il
faut quitter cette culture de la guerre
entre les administrations elles ont
chacune leur rôle et je pense que le
travail qui sera fait
j'espère qu'il a commencé à être fait de
décloisonnement du système sanitaire
social et médico-social est absolument
est absolument indispensable
je note d'ailleurs que au delà des
procès qui ont été faits et qu'ils ont
été mal vécue dans les ars des
caricatures absolument odieuses des
personnels qui ont parfois travailler
deux jours et deux nuits dans les ars
présentés comme des assassins
alors qu'ils se sont mobilisés d'une
manière extraordinaire
je pense par exemple à un aurélien
rousseau à la tête de l' ars d'île de
france mais de bien d'autres ces procès
était largement injuste
demain il y aura je l'espère un vaccin
il y aura même des vaccins j'attire est
d'une certaine façon ce n'est pas le
fait de trouver un vaccin qui est plus
difficile c'est le fait d'opérer une
vaccination car cela exige une
logistique absolument considérable il
s'agit de savoir d'abord quel vaccin on
va acheter car nous nous sommes trouvés
devant de mémoire presque une dizaine de
fournisseurs de vaccins
ce que j'ai voulu c'est que cette c'est
pour nice heures soit diversifiée pour
ne pas être entre les mains d'un seul
fournisseur qu'ils aient une certaine
surface de fabrication pour prévenir les
aléas de livraison et qu'ils soient
évidemment procurer au moindre coût
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
procédé à des commandes g4 fournisseurs
les plus fiables 50 millions de
pandemrix vaccin adjuvanté auprès du
laboratoire gsk 16 millions de fausses
et ria chez novartis vaccins également
adjuvanté avec un adjuvant différents 28
millions chez sanofi aventis de panenza
vaccin non adjuvanté mais livrables très
postérieurement aux deux premiers ainsi
qu'une toute petite commande de 50 mille
chez baxter
r les vaccins les plus coûteux
commercialisé sous le nom de ces valent
pas mais cette commande de 50 milles qui
nous a été livrée dès le mois de
septembre me permettait de faire
vacciner les femmes enceintes
nous n'avons obtenu que 50000 car il y
en avait très peu ensuite il me faut
expliquer pourquoi j'ai commandé 94
millions de doses
car étant donné le panier de conneries
que j'entends sur cette affaire je suis
heureuse de donner quelques explications
ça y est je suis remonté j'ai appuyé sur
le bouton et je vais donc déroulé
l'explication
d'abord je n'ai pas acheté 94 millions
de vaccins que j'ai acheté 94 millions
de doses puisqu'il fallait un vaccin est
un rappel
donc j'ai acheté 47 millions de vaccins
la caractéristique de ces vaccins était
d'être présenté en boîte n'est content
non des conditionnables de 500 doses ce
n'était pas une des moindres difficultés
de la logistique car quand on reçoit
deux millions de doses
on ne reçoit que quatre mille boîtes de
vaccins
on peut déconditionner du paracétamol on
peut pas déconditionner des vaccins j'ai
imaginé de pouvoir l'aider conditionné
mais il faut créer un laboratoire avec
des chambres à 4° des personnels qu'on
équipes susceptibles de rejeter
évidemment ces produits la possibilité
et le le fait de procéder à des
injections dans des centres de
vaccination permettait de réduire les
pertes de façon considérable parce que
quand vous avez piqué une seringue dans
le bouchon da multidoses vous êtes
contraints de jeter le flacon de vaccins
à la fin de la journée
même si le vaccin à du thiomersal en
désinfectant
donc vous avez si vous utilisez un
centre de vaccination vous avez une
perte d'environ 10% plus l'arrosoir se
disperse plus la perte est grande
donc nous avons limité la casse si l'on
puis dire
en décidant d'opérer par centres de
vaccination ce qui était d'ailleurs
rendu absolument indispensable par la
dispensation dans ces boîtes de 500
doses non des conditionnels nous avions
donc 42 millions de vaccins utilisable
nous sommes le seul pays à avoir utilisé
le concept de coefficient d'attrition
ça signifie que nous avons décidé que un
certain nombre même en cas de pandémie
grave à certain nombre de nos
concitoyens ne se ferait pas vacciner
pour bâtir ce coefficient d'attrition
qui est une construction intellectuelle
nous avons pris deux références les
intentions de vaccination telle qu'elle
apparaissait dans l'opinion publique
mais également dans les bassins de
méningite
sous l'effet du stress d'une épidémie de
méningite des gens qui se faisait
vacciner qui était située entre 80 et
90%
je reconnais que cette construction du
coefficient d'attrition peut poser débat
et qu'on peut juger qu'elles étaient
soit trop ambitieux soit pas assez mais
nous l'avons fixé à 33 %
d'où ce chiffre de 42 millions de
vaccins pour une population peu près de
65 millions d'habitants dans les regrets
que j'ai et qui me poursuivent parfois
là je me dis mais si la pandémie avait
été grave
n'ai-je pas indiquer un coefficient
d'attrition trop élevé je dois dire que
les pays équivalent ont été beaucoup
plus ambitieux je rappelle que j'ai donc
acheté 94 millions de doses mais que la
grande bretagne en a acheté 130
milliards que les pays bas avec 17
millions d'habitants non acheter 34
millions que l'autriche avec millions
d'habitants en acheté 16 millions et que
les états unis et barack obama voulait
acheter 600 millions de doses
ils ne l'ont pas fait parce qu'ils n'ont
pas trouvé le marché et suffisants c'est
à dire qu'ils ont décidé de protéger
leurs populations sans coefficient
d'attrition est ce qui est tout à fait
remarquable c'est que personne dans ces
pays n'a fait procès gouvernement de
l'achat des vaccins beaucoup plus
important qu ici il n'ya qu'en france
en france seulement que cette affaire a
fait scandale et un mille gouvernement
en accusation
merci caroline fiat
la france est soumise merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre vous nous
parliez tout à l'heure de mots que j'ai
trouvé faible moqueries et mis en cause
jeu j'étais à l'époque élèves aides
soignantes
quand vous étiez du coup ma ministre
sauf que depuis nous avions tous les
soignants bien du mal de faire entendre
raison dès qu'il faut parler de gestes
barrières de de prévention du mot
sanitaires et à chaque fois et encore
aujourd'hui je suis bien contente que
dès le début de vos propos vous avez dit
que nous étions encore en crise il faut
merci faisait très peu le disent et
regrettez-vous que 20 regrettez vous
vous avez donc mis en place un protocole
normal de prévention pour protéger les
citoyens aujourd'hui je lui dire grâce
aux coronavirus on vous donne raison dix
ans plus tard mais aujourd'hui quand on
dit aux gens de mettre des masques ou de
se protéger on entend encore le h1n1 on
en fait toujours de trop beaucoup de
choses comme ça
pensez vous que quelles préconisations
pourriez vous faire pour que la
communication puisse changer
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui avec le recul et
avec du coup la preuve que tout ce que
vous aviez mis en place quelle
communication pourrait être fait pour
qu'enfin les français suivent les règles
sanitaires dans notre pays
lors de mon propos liminaire j'ai
indiqué que je saucisses je souhaitais
que une des leçons que nous puissions
tirer de cette de ces pandémies soit la
création d'une société résiliente une
société résiliente c'est à dire une
société où
chaque citoyen s'empare de sa protection
le problème c'est que nous avons une
société qui sans doute pratique trop la
gestion ascendantes et descendantes des
crises qui aboutit une certaine avant
utilisation une certaine contestation
nous devons tous nous emparer du risque
pandémique des risques quels qu'ils
soient sanitaires environnementales ou
technologiques
j'ai été frappé par un certain nombre de
choses
la première chose que j'ai fait avec les
masques c'est d'en équiper les ehpad
canche et commencer la la gestion de
cette crise pandémique mais enfin dans
les ehpad il y a des des représentants
des conseils généraux
il faut sonner l'alertent des concerts
bars dont le président jean que
j'utilise d'anciens thermes des conseils
départementaux ge
j'ai une vieille dame de 74 ans donc
vous savez pendant quitter les mauvaises
habitudes et dictant il faut s'en saisir
les conseils régionaux sont les
stimulateurs de l'activité économique
mais pourquoi n'ont ils pas imaginer une
filière de réactifs et de tests enfin
ils attendent quoi les conseils
municipaux ils sont là ils peuvent
équiper un certain nombre
d'administrations
[Musique]
j'ai entendu un représentant d'un
syndicat de médecins dire nous n'avions
pas de masque dans nos cabinets m'enfin
des médecins qui n'ont pas de masque
dans leurs cabinets qui se constitue pas
un stock
nous n'avions pas de blues mais enfin
pourquoi les médecins ne porte plus de
blues
qu'est ce que c'est que cette dent pays
de pasteur qu'est ce que c'est que cette
médecine où on ne croit plus à la ccir
vous dites les gens croient puis au
masque mais quand un médecin viennent
boire pour une angine à streptocoques
qu'il arrive sans masque semble ou
sens avait les mains qui me posent sur
le torse
très beau d'ailleurs au passage mais un
stéthoscope qui n'a même pas désinfecté
qu'il repart sans se laver les mains
sans masquer semble où et pourquoi est
ce qu'on n'a pas des blues
pourquoi c'est ça n'existe plus avec une
machine à laver à l'intérieur du du
cabinet médical mais enfin on attend que
le préfet ou le directeur de la rs
viennent avec une petite charrette
porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays est
infantilisé il faut quand même un peu se
prendre en main dans ce pays c'est sa
valse on qu'il faut tirer tant qu'on
donc on a 30 doit donc on attendra tout
du seigneur du château
on est mal martin wagner pour le groupe
edf
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
alors peut-être oui je pense que vous
avez raison les médecins libéraux se
souviendront que ils n'avaient pas de
protection puisque 46 ont payé de leur
vie durant cette cette crise cosider
peut-être faisait t-il trop confiance
justement en la capacité de l'état de
les protéger en temps et en heure et
merci oui ou collectivités territoriales
qui notamment dans le grand est
que ce soit le conseil régional où les
conseils départementaux qui ont su
réagir très vite pour passer des
commandes puisque puisque les
protections que ce soit ma secoué le
pays ne venait pas suffisamment vite
ma question je vais reparler veuillez
m'en excuser des vaccins ne pensez-vous
pas donc que
donc il y avait eu cette commande de 47
millions de vaccins au fond 8% seulement
de la population a été vaccinée à ce
moment là or on sait très bien qu'il
peut y avoir des immunités croisés alors
est-ce que ça peut être une piste
d'interprétation j'aimerais vous
entendre et peut-être aussi du coup
pourrions-nous avoir cette même logique
sur le colis 19 que de parler d'
immunité creuser avec d'autres d'autres
vaccinations orient c'est quand même que
la france se situe assez bien dans la
vaccination antigrippale et une dernière
question c'est vrai que vous avez été
sûr dans les médias assez sévères contre
le professeur raoult pendant cette crise
et notamment sur l'utilisation de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine vous avez dit il
me semble que cette ce médicament qu'il
fallait faire extrêmement attention
puisqu'il pouvait avoir des effets
secondaires qu'on ne maîtrisait pas or
vous êtes pharmacienne vous savez très
bien que ont fait des études de
pharmacovigilance de façon très sérieuse
dans notre pays et que l'asm
en tout cas pour les trois dernières
années 2017 2018 2019 avait remonté
seulement deux cas de cas de patients
qui était alors un qui s'était suicidée
malheureusement avec l'hydro xi
chloroquine et l'autre passion qui en
prenait qui est très âgées poli medic et
aidons l'imputabilité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine vis-à-vis du décès n'a
jamais pu être démontré donc je vous ai
trouvé très sévères vis-à-vis de cette
molécule pendant pendant la crise merci
un premier point sur les collectivités
territoriales
les collectivités territoriales ont
acheté des masques au moment où tout le
monde en acheter ce n'est pas faire de
l'anticipation ce que j'aurais souhaité
c'est que les collectivités
territoriales comme d'autres phases de
l'anticipation bien avant finalement il
ya peut-être plutôt une désorganisation
des marchés des masques à ce moment là
plutôt qu'une organisation et une course
à l'échalote qui a plutôt renchéri le
coût des masques que de les abaisser
ensuite sur la vaccination
je rappelle bien sûr que l'épidémie
s'étend déclarer au fur et à mesure des
mois moins sévère les gens ne se sont
plus fait vacciner c'est vrai d'autant
qu'il y a dans notre pays un mouvement
antivaccinal très très important est une
caractéristique de la france et dans le
pays pasteur en parlait c'est quand même
absolument navrant de voir cette
antipathie cette antipathie pour les
vaccins qui est qui ne laisse pas qu'il
me laisse pas d'être d'être stupéfaite
néanmoins la stratégie vaccinale que
j'ai adopté qui était de vacciner les
publics les plus fragiles a eu un effet
multiplicateur puisque effectivement ce
qui propage l'épidémie
c'est que des personnes 6
le se comportent comme des propagateurs
de la pandémie et vous connaissez
suffisamment la façon dont ça se
prononce à se propage pour savoir que la
vaccination a toujours un effet
populationnelle supérieur à son action
individuelle
je ne sais pas si j'ai été sévère avec
le professeur raoul temps je sais en
tout cas que à ma demande il a reçu la
subvention la plus importante jamais
donné à une structure biomédicale je ne
sais pas si je suis sévère avec le
professeur raoul tu mais il a reçu une
subvention de 72,4 millions d'euros pour
fondelia chu de marseille
si j'étais sévère avec lui
alors là franchement non car il faut pas
oublier que dans la stratégie pandémique
nous avons voulu créer un institut de
hautes technologies pour justement
préparer l'avenir dans cette stratégie
de préparation à une pandémie
la création de l'ia chu a été une
volonté politique forte dans le cadre
des dépenses d'avenir voulue par le
président sarkozy
merci mais ce sont deux forget merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chiant ça fait quelques auditions
m'attends donc on entend des gens qu ou
certains ministres par exemple qui vous
disent moi je n'avais pas le nez dans
les stocks dont je ne sais pas parler à
mon dgs je rendais des ges ils nous ont
parlé aux pharmaciens de l'eprus ou
parler à un terrien et on sait plus on
sait plus comprendre plus bien puis et
puis après vous
pardon et puis après je vous entends
vous dire vous même
je suis une vieille femme de 74 ans et
moi je suis choquée parce que je vous ai
pas connu comme politique mais sur votre
plateau télévision je vous ai toujours
vu comme une jeune femme très alerte et
cetera et puis et là je vous entends
parler maintenant commission pour
remémorer votre travail politique
d'époque et finalement je vous entend
surtout les présentes sur tous les
fronts moi je j'accorde beaucoup de
valeur à ce que vous avez fait sur la
prévention à l'époque et surtout je vous
entends en connaissance des stocks des
visions d'avenir de moi j'ai
l'impression qu'être ministre de la
santé
à votre époque si vous me permettez
c'est pas le même travail que ce que
d'autres sont venus nous racontez vous
êtes au courant de tout tout vous
remontre vous choisissez vous fait vous
vous nous expliquer maintenant même être
à l'origine la création des médias chum
est donc si vous voulez moi je vous
serais tu as juste vous demander ça est
ce qu'être ministre en votre temps c'est
être au courant de tout de tout depuis
la gestion des stocks
jusqu'aux questions d'anticipation et
est ce que peut-être l'organisation
actuelle est délétère finalement à la
gestion d'une crise telle que celle que
nous avons connue
merci d'abord je voulais vous remercier
de vos compliments qui sont toujours
agréables à recevoir plus sérieusement
est-ce que ministre c'est être au
courant de tout oui oui c'est être au
courant de tout
et si on n'est pas au courant de quelque
chose s'arranger pour le savoir c'est à
dire temps c'est son directeur de
cabinet le directeur d'une
administration centrale pour que les
renseignements vous parviennent dans
l'eure et même pour avant-hier quand on
est en charge de la de l'état et d'un
service de l'état et d'un ministère il
faut tout connaître
bien sûr jusqu'au nom des fonctionnaires
qui vous servent c'est évident merci
alors jean pierre pont
merci madame la présidente d'abord une
petite anecdote j'ai retrouvé des
documents lors de la crise du h1n1
lavez vous les mains ne vous serrez pas
les mains donc on oublie très vite dans
tous les cas tout à l'heure vous aviez
vous avez dit que vous aviez agi avec
les moyens les connaissances que vous
aviez ça c'est tout à fait normal chacun
agit comme cela mais a posteriori compte
tenu de ce que nous avons connaissance
maintenant qu'auriez-vous fait ou pu
faire de mieux
merci
de se vautrer dans les délices de la
lucidité a posteriori ce qui est
toujours quelque chose de d'agréable il
ya des choses que je regrette j'en ai
déjà dit une je n'ai pas acheté assez de
vaccins
ça c'est sûr j'aurais dû ne pas calculer
de coefficient d'attrition si je veux
être raccord avec ma ligne de prévention
maximum j'ai objectivement pris un
risque deuxièmement j'aurais souhaité
garder les manettes entière sur la
gestion de la crise et ne pas la
partager avec le ministère de
l'intérieur à partir du moment où on est
passé au niveau 4 ce n'était pas de mon
fait
mais j'estime que c'est
c'est dommageable ensuite je regrette de
n'avoir pas pu continuer ce que j'aurais
souhaité en particulier dans le cadre de
cette gestion résilient de cette france
résiliente au risque et je l'examen peu
comme un testament
je souhaiterais que notre pays imagine
des structures dormantes de prise en
charge d'une pandémie
par exemple j'avais imaginé les médecins
généralistes avait regretté de ne pas
pouvoir vacciner
nous ne pouvions pas étant donné les
livraisons mais imaginons que nous ayons
eue dès le début comme nous les avons
vus à partir du mois de janvier des
unidoses ce qui permettaient de confier
la vaccination médecin généraliste pour
autant etait-il équipe et si
il y avait une pandémie c'est à dire de
mélanger une population saine avec une
population malade est ce qu'on n'aurait
pas pu imaginer ce qu'on ne peut pas
imaginer de faire une organisation
territoriale dormantes avec des cabinets
médicaux qui seraient des cabinets de
référence qui permettrait la vaccination
et de confier ainsi aux personnes à des
médecins des médecins référents qui
aurait par exemple deux entrées dans
leur cabinet dentaire qui auraient la
possibilité d'avoir un frigo qui serait
parfaitement aux normes avec un
évidement un groupe électrogène en cas
de coupure électrique et de les équiper
au besoin avec l'aide de l'état et de
l'assurance maladie
donc d'imaginer cette préparation à
cette préparation dormantes qui
permettrait également dans les
entreprises de vérifier qu'il y à un
référent pandémie qu'il s'occupe des
stocks de masques de la préparation des
personnels
voyez c'est toutes ces structures
dormantes moi je je pense que c'est dans
cette voie qu'il faut aller et je
regrette vraiment de n'avoir pas pu
imaginer cela de la façon la plus
opérationnel possible
je pense que c'est là que nous allons
créer une société résiliente haut risque
merci jean jacques gauthier oui mesdames
la ministre avait rappelé la création
des ars la loi hpst 2009 2010 nous y
étions le but c'était de rationaliser de
décloisonner la rs reste un outil alors
un outil comme tous les outils on peut
bien s'en servir au moins bien s'en
servir
je voudrais avoir votre position sur la
place des crs dans la crise que nous
venons de vivre
la vocation de l'hôpital avant tout de
soigner et certains ont pu s'interroger
sur la paire les récents événements sur
le fait est ce qu'il était adapté de
confier un organisme qui est quand même
à vocation essentiellement budgétaire la
gestion d'une crise sanitaire j'en veux
la position de jean rottner qui est
quelqu'un de très tolérant et qui à la
fois en tant que président de la région
grand est qui était particulièrement
touché et est chef de service des
urgences à mulhouse qui a vu débarquer
des tas de patients s'est interrogé à ce
sujet il ya cet aspect parfois un peu
déconnectés du terrain
mais là aussi parce que le territoire a
vraiment augmenté
l'art est grand test va des bords de
seine au bord du rhin c'est pour elle
qu'on avait connue et puis cette vision
essentiellement budgétaire qui peut être
déconnecté de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire est de même sur la dualité
préférait si j'ai entendu votre votre
position plusieurs professeurs de
médecine qui ont été des gs je pense aux
professeurs d'hab je prends son
professeur houssin vous êtes bien connus
eux regretter cette dualité préfet ars
aller en disant que c'était pas une
bonne chose
il préférait que le préfet finalement
soit aux manettes en raison de son côté
interministérielle en raison de son
pouvoir de réquisition et aussi en
raison d'une meilleure connaissance des
élus le saas est indiscutable on
constate tous les jours en tant qu' en
tant que député montant que
le local merci jean pierre
ma vision des ars n'était pas une vision
budgétaire même si par définition dans
un système solidaire les questions
budgétaires dalons dame qui fixait des
dépenses de santé qui sont financées par
les cotisations des personnes enfin qui
sont financés de façon classique à peu
près en grande masse à 47% par les
cotisations sur les salariés à 37% par
un impôt qui s'appelle la csg et le
reste par des taxes affectées par les
tabac les alcools et les mutuelles
évidemment pèse directement sur le
pouvoir d'achat des des cotisants et des
gens qui sont ainsi et des gens qui sont
ainsi imposés directement ou
indirectement donc la question du
financement n'est pas une question
injurieuse ou mal placé d'autant que si
l'on vit bien se référer à la santé
publique
ce ne sont pas les dépenses de santé qui
sont les plus impliqués dans les
améliorations qu'on peut attendre au
niveau de la santé oms qu'il faut avoir
une vision sans doute plus globale
puisque toutes les dépenses que l'on
impute indûment aux systèmes sanitaires
ce sont des dépenses qu'on ne mettra pas
dans l'éducation dans le logement dans
dans l'amélioration des conditions de
vie dans les questions environnementales
il faut aussi avoir une vision globale
des choses donc faire de la bonne
gestion d'un système de santé n'est pas
indécent bien au contraire le juste soin
la juste dépenses c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait important bien sûr il faut
un moment lâché les chiens et aux
particuliers au moment d'une pandémie
c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est j'ai
l'impression que c'est ce qui a été fait
pour autant que j'en sache
et c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
utile à situations d'urgence
j'ai entendu un quoi qu'il en coûte
je pense que c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait normal et judicieux ceci
étant ça ne peut pas être une politique
à long terme
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est une
politique d'urgence momentanée est à
manier avec toutes les précautions
nécessaires
alors j'ai bien sûr entendu plusieurs
fois sur mon plateau jean rottner que
j'aime beaucoup et je veux saluer son
action à la fois d'élus et de
d'urgentistes tout à fait remarquable
c'est l'occasion pour moi aussi saluer
tous les soignants qui se sont mobilisés
dans ce domaine mais réfléchir à
l'amélioration de notre système de santé
est une absolue nécessité
je trouve que le procès récurrents qui
est fait aux administrations et à
l'assurance maladie de considérer par
exemple l'hôpital comme une entreprise
est un procès absurde pour personne
hôpital et newton est une entreprise au
sens capitaliste du terme
c'est une belle entreprise humaine c'est
pas parce que c'est une entreprise
humaine d'ailier ou soit qu'elle ne doit
pas réfléchir sa bonne gestion
annie gendt et merci magma président
madame la ministre
j'aurais voulu vous interroger sur
partir de votre propos liminaire dans
lequel vous avez indiqué que nous avions
besoin d'outils plutôt que de procédure
pourquoi je voudrais vous interrogé
là-dessus parce que effectivement tout
on a condamné mme ont tendance à vous
suivre dans ce raisonnement et j'observe
que en asie où je suis élue
les asiatiques ont beaucoup plus de
procédures que d'outils parfois ce qui
peut leur porter tort au sila de l'est
c'est pas forcément non plus la panacée
mais est derrière vous avez indiqué que
nous manquions et je vous rejoins
totalement de structures dormantes
je pense qu'effectivement tout la
description vous en avez fait est
vraiment absolument nécessaire et on
voit combien il est difficile de faire
passer ce message dans la population
et pourtant une fois qu'on a des
structures dormantes derrière il faut
aussi savoir les utiliser
donc j'en reviens aux procédures donc je
pense que les deux là n'est pas exclusif
de l'autre et qu'il faut probablement
les deux mais s'agissant maintenant des
gestes barrières dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure vous avez évoqué pour lesquels
il a été dit qu hélas vous les aviez
vous l'avez vous même dit vous avez mis
en place une politique pour essayer de
développer ces gestes barrières et il a
été souligné par m mes collègues tout à
l'heure combien hélas cela avait été
oublié et ses gestes barrières ne sont
finalement toujours pas passé dans le
quotidien de nos concitoyens j'allais
dire comme se laver les dents tous les
matins mais je crains que ce ne soit pas
encore le geste quotidien de tout le
monde
alors j'aurais voulu vous interrogez un
ami sûr à votre avis qu'est ce avec
votre expérience
que peut-on faire que quelques manque
t-il à une politique publique pour qu'un
geste d'une telle importance on le
comprend là aujourd'hui puissent
véritablement s'ancrer dans le quotidien
de nos concitoyens
j'ai déjà en partie répondu à votre
question en indiquant qu'il compte bien
que cette société devienne résiliente
dans une prise de responsabilité des
citoyens
si dans une entreprise
j'avais en juin je vais retrouver la
date où directeur le 3 juillet 2009
j'avais en jouant directeur général du
travail jean-denis combrexelle l'époque
de sortir une circulaire sur la
continuité de l'activité économique avec
une réserve de masques dans les
entreprises et en particulier de fp2
pour les salariés en contact avec le
public un site les personnels qui manie
les déchets les ordures ménagères est en
joie de procéder sur le compte des
entreprises pas de l'état par
l'intermédiaire de l'ugap à ces achats
de masques
donc ça c'est 3 juillet 2009
nous n'avions pas encore le premier cas
car je voulais que l'activité économique
soit ainsi préservé à partir du moment
où la prise de responsabilité et
diffusée dans le public je pense que le
respect des mesures barrière est
beaucoup plus accepter si c'est l'état
qui dit porter un masque à 1
ivo rüthemann le ministre d'abord on
l'aiment pas le ministre d'abord parce
qu'on soutient pas sa politique peu ce
qu'on trouve que ça lui plaît peuple
c'est un gars tout doit être une fille
d'ailleurs qui doit être dans un palais
dorés avec des meubles louis 15 et des
huissiers à chaîne qui lui ouvre la
porte
évidemment ce gala peut pas connaître la
réalité des choses mais si vous avez
dans l'entreprise un référent pandémie
qui vous dit à des stocks de masques ont
réuni les salariés on regarde comment on
fait je crois que là on peut faire en
sorte que les mesures barrières soient
acceptés de la même façon dans des lieux
de de théâtre dans des lieux de enfin de
culture dans des lieux d'éducation
c'est effectivement par la diffusion
dans une société résilient de ces
mesures qu'on y arrivera tout ce qui
viendra d'en haut ne sera pas acceptée
donnera lieu à un procès politique
d'autant que la politique française est
devenue tellement émietter les dernières
élections municipales l'ont montré j'ai
été évidemment frappé à la fois par
l'abstention et par le fait que nombre
de maires seront élite façon minoritaire
ce qui était pas l'habitude dans notre
pays au monde à des verts qui vont gérer
les villes avec 15% des inscrits quand
on a 60 % d'abstention et qu'on obtient
40% des voix
pour certains le calcul est facile à
faire
donc la parole politique est tellement
décrédibiliser émietté que tout ce qui
paraîtra tous qui viendra d'en haut sera
ressentie comme une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles
donc il faut vraiment que cette société
résiliente donne la parole aux citoyens
et la responsabilité aux citoyens ils
peuvent la prendre d'ailleurs d'ores et
déjà il faut qu'il le fasse
c'est la seule façon merci monsieur le
rapporteur vous aviez des choses rares
oui peut-être pour conclure en vous
remerciant madame la ministre une
question d'abord vous avez une phrase
dans votre propos en réponse à une
question dans votre propos liminaire
vous avez indiqué la réforme
territoriale
vous y avez ajouté un qualificatif je
crois funès au désastreuse de 2015 en
tout cas je peux faire mienne cette
appréciation a porté un coup fatal aux
ars
parce que je nage in que ce que vous
avez dit mais est ce que j'imagine que
ce sont des régions des territoires trop
grand par rapport à la nécessaire
proximité que qui était prévu
initialement dans des régions de
périmètres plus modestes d'abord la
taille des régions je veux pas rentrer
dans ce débat on a estimé que les
régions françaises était trop petit on a
pris d'ailleurs des exemples
parfaitement non pertinent en
particulier des exemples allemands lors
qu'elle est toute petite région en
allemagne il ya même des villes régions
qui marchent ma foi pas si mal ensuite
cette affaire a été présentée comme une
mesure d'économie qu'elle n'a été qu'une
façon elle a même généré des dépenses
supplémentaires et tous les éléments
d'appréciation qui ont été faits sur
cette réforme territoriale indique
qu'elle n'a généré elle a donc généré
aucune économie
enfin troisièmement effectivement pour
les ars qui sont d administration de
proximité certes avec des délégations
départementales enfin au niveau régional
on peut se poser la question de la
taille mais après tout si ces régions
avaient préexisté à la création des ars
et que les ars s'étaient installés sur
une certaine configuration territoriale
mais la réforme survient cinq ans après
que cette administration adolescentes se
soit installée conclut c'est ces raisons
installer ces hommes et ces femmes enfin
c'est un coup de poignard épouvantable
qu'on a mis dans le dos des ars que
cette réforme territoriale
quand je les ai vu surgir je me suis dit
mais les directeurs des ars m'appelle
leur maman désolé jusqu'à ce qu'ils vont
dire mes bébés drs cette affaire s'était
c'était c'était terrible merci ensuite
vous nous avez dit un ministre doit être
au courant de tout peut pas être au
courant de tout mais il devrait être en
tout cas peut-être est-ce que pour vous
un ministre doit être être informés de
l'état des stocks stratégiques et
notamment d' du nombre de masques dans
un pays un ministre doit être informée
il s'agit pas tous les matins que vous
ayez note qui vous disent on en est là
du stock
bien entendu mais la politique des
masques c'est le ministre qui en décide
le bon de commande des masques il est
passé soit par la lèvre par délégation
évidemment par la dgs l'eprus enfin par
une chaîne ou que l'on connaît bien mais
la politique elle est décidée par le
ministre est décidée par le gouvernement
donc on s'inquiète à intervalles
réguliers
que ce soit parce que vous recevez le
directeur de l'eprus qui vient vous
tenir au courant de ce qui se passe dans
son vous le recevrez personnellement
nouveau directeur de cabinet vous
et tu me manques et en suisse ah oui
c'est ça et ensuite quand on est comment
dirais-je quand on est dans une
situation de crise le directeur de
cabinet à votre indications téléphone ou
directeur de l'eprus je pense qu'ils
font bien avoir une heure pour avoir
l'état des stocks
merci madame la ministre après je sors
peut-être un peu de mon rôle de
rapporteur mais de deux remarques parce
que je vous ai trouvé un peu injuste ou
ou un peu sévère à la fois sur les
médecins de ville sur leur capacité à se
protéger parce que ils se sont trouvés
aussi dans une situation de pénurie où
il ne pouvait plus acquérir ces
équipements de protection parce qu'il
n'y en avait plus il y en avait pas et
n'avait pas dans les pharmacies donc
c'est vrai que certains avaient un stock
de précaution mais au bout d'un certain
temps la crise a duré plusieurs semaines
durent encore ils se sont trouvés
confrontés à cette pénurie donc je
trouve que votre appréciation est
peut-être un bain juste de même pour les
collectivités locales
là je vous le dis je sors de mon rôle
même de député parce que j'ai présidé
quand vous savez question de travailler
ensemble département pendant près de
neuf ans nous avions acheté dans ce
cadre plusieurs mains stocks de masques
nous en avions encore il ya quelques
semaines au début de la crise 600000
donc il ya des collectivités qui avait
anticipé d'ailleurs qui ont été
réquisitionnés et mis à disposition des
soignants avec une évaluation sur la
péremption qui a été trois fois revu et
dans l'achat aussi des masques pour ceux
qui n'avaient pas disposition je trouve
que les collectivités ont pallié des
manque cruel et que heureusement qu'il
ya eu des collectivités je vois dans
département niveau des villes au niveau
de la région qui ont acheté des millions
de masques et qui ont été utiles parce
que c'était quelques fois les seuls à
disposition pendant plusieurs semaines
oui enfin je le rappelle parce que c'est
toujours bien de dire les choses
au passage non mais je parle pas de la
protection évidemment au moment de la
crise pandémique
il est trop tard mais là aussi dans
cette société résiliente que un cabinet
médical mais en dehors de toute crise au
moment de la crise effectivement il peut
plus se procurer des masses mais des
masques 7,1 c'est quand même pas quelque
chose de haute technologie même si il
faut quand même pas faire n'importe quoi
dans les masques mais là aussi constitué
un stock de protection qui vous permet
d'assurer mettons un mois de pandémie en
attendant que les choses puissent se
réguler c'est pas compliqué c'est un
investissement mais tout petit
investissement au niveau d'un cabinet
médical et qu'on le regarde de façon
régulière
évidemment vous avez raison eric ciotti
si on essaie de se procurer des masques
au moment de la pandémie il y en a pas y
en a nulle part c'est c'est une course
évidemment impossible donc il faut
véritablement qu'un certain nombre
d'institutions dont des médecins est
évidemment dans leurs cabinets médicaux
à stocks de précaution qui corresponde à
un mois d'activités et des blues une
machine à laver et voilà il faut
absolument dans ce pays de pasteur on
retrouve les règles de la sepsie dans
les hôpitaux psy ou je ne peux que
constater la désastreuse habitude de la
barbe chez les soignants il fut un temps
où la barbe était interdite véritables
nids à microbes je ne
comprends pas qu'on soit barbu dans un
hôpital
c'est désolant mais c'est comme ça de
voir les blues largement ouverte sur les
complets vestons passe comme si la
blouse était une espèce de d'accessoires
de théâtre qu'on mettait de la cape de
cyrano banon je suis désolé je suis une
vieille bête mais c'est ça je peux je
tant pis pour les barbus qui sont
présents ici
mais madame la ministre ou les vous
remercie infiniment pour le temps que
vous nous avez accordé et vos réponses
qui détonne vous venez d'entendre
roselyne bachelot une phrase à retenir
de cette audition l'ancien ministre de
la santé actuel ministre de la culture a
fustigé un pays je cite infantiliser qui
attend que le directeur de cabinet du
préfet ou de la rs viennent avec une
petite charrette porter des masques
un franc parler qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir les députés mais aussi les
médecins
cette audition et toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à retrouver
tout l'été sur lcp et sur notre site
internet
lcp point fr